hey Mark
um a little birdie told me that you have
won unpaid parking ticket that's funny
because a little birdie told me that
your adoptive mother was arrested for
marijuana possession
what you didn't know that huh
I didn't know I was adopted
[Music]
no offense but maybe you think I'm going
too fast because you're going too slow
then no offense but I'm going slow
because I might lose my job okay no
offense but maybe that's a little bit of
an excuse for not acting on your
feelings no offense do not remember you
having a Nursing degree and feelings
offense that's rude I'm gonna go dance
douche her up
I don't know how to explain hey Mark the
shoe shot stand still doesn't have that
syphilis medication you were asking
about
and hey what a coincidence are you in
this office purely for business reasons
pleasure actually my boyfriend Mark
works here he's sitting right next to me
hey Andy well I guess I'll see you guys
around see ya oh uh also Mark again we
don't have those extra small condoms you
ordered
I called the factory it's going to take
a special order not just because of the
size but because of the weird shape as
well something they've never dealt with
before we'll talk you want to come home
with me don't you work at Lady Foot
Locker
if any of you need anything at all too
bad
deal with your problems yourselves like
adults yippee road trip who's excited to
go to Bloomington is that where you're
gonna sit
I'm driving where else would I sit trunk
Miss nope how's that zero dollar bid
coming along you know in my experience
with capitalism people normally expect
money in exchange for their goods and
land in my experience with butt faces
you are one all right that's basically
it water the plants get the mail can I
read your mail no please don't
fine oh and um here are the keys and
remember I know don't let Tom make a
copy that's right good I'm paying April
50 bucks to watch my house while I'm
away I would have asked Leslie but
I've seen the way she takes care of her
house plus there's always been a little
distance between me and April
and I thought this would baby I don't
know give us a chance to get a little
closer maybe even I don't like Anne we
have a couple House rolls though yeah
sure of course you can't use the front
door you have to climb in through the
back window no personal phone
conversations if you ever speak to me in
Spanish please use the formal instead I
don't know if I made it clear but I
don't want any sex offenders in our
Parks catalog well Photoshop his face
can you photoshop your life with better
decisions Jerry okay April I know Tammy
hello Ron what happened here and more
importantly
does the carpet match the face if you're
looking for trouble take it somewhere
else an hour ago a giant Fireball
consumed my entire face and it was far
preferable to spending another second
with you
I guess I'll be heading home
catching the number 12 bus to Satan's
butthole
hey getting ready for your nightly Skype
date with Andy in London you look lovely
I'm going to murder you a thousand times
okay
what the hell
someone's back from London no it's not
the queen someone's back from London
it's not Mr Bean it's not the royal baby
and kiss me
oh my God what are you doing here I just
missed you so bad honey I bought myself
a ticket home you're never going to need
that computer again
because I'm home for like 19 hours this
is so sweet just like the old days take
a hike Jerry it's Larry now okay take a
hike Larry
is this land mine still functional
partially
why because I want to blow up Donna's
desk so I can teach her a lesson about
what happens when you skip work I'm not
sure that's how you should go about this
I'm kind of her boss now but I still
feel weird disciplining her what do I do
look her in the eyes and tell her
exactly what you need from her be mature
direct and firm
advice I very maturely and
straightforwardly left Anonymous
comments about Donna online
so Dennis not to interrupt then don't
boom shut him right down I have heard so
much talking from you I don't want to
hear your fat mouth say anything else
you're a dick
excuse me what's your problem okay guys
guys just hold it hold on a sec okay Mr
Feinstein with all due respect
you are a major dick what run ready get
my crossbow crossbow what the you will
pay for this computers are mostly
pointless but that Yelp thing gave me a
great idea on how to criticize people in
places
I am composing strongly worded letters
about things I disapprove of and I am
using the internet to get addresses
where I can send them so far I've
written to a vegetable farm several
European ambassadors a manufacturer of
male cologne and a non-fat Frozen Yogurt
Bar
dear frozen yogurt you are the celery of
desserts be ice cream or be nothing zero
Stars
okay this is the really exciting part we
buy tetrachloroethylene at a dollar
sixty a gallon but we sell it back at
238 a gallon now I know what you're
thinking what if it's a cleaner who
wants to buy glycol ethers Ben stop
this is so aring this is like listening
to a TED Talk by the color beige look I
know this idea doesn't excite you but I
promise it'll make you a lot of money
well I sold tons of awesome stuff
guess it makes sense my next challenge
is to sell something mind-numbingly dull
dull
does this look dull to you
Ben the jerk is here who are that one
the one coming over here get ready okay
let's be professional hi hello Ben
um
look uh I kind of feel like we got off
on the wrong foot so I just wanted to
stop by yeah we'll save your breath okay
get out of here because this is a party
with my friends and you're trying to
fire all my friends plus I just talked
to everybody in this bar and nobody
wants you here
um okay then I'll I'll just see you
tomorrow sorry to bother you get out of
here
let's see
well let's go set up this party April
thank you I know you may tease and but
deep down inside I can tell that you
really care Anne's leaving town and
saying painful goodbyes loved ones
greatest day of my life
hey I'm thinking about getting a new
phone do you guys like your phones I've
never used a phone in my life
what about you Ron do you like your
phone
and so when I finally cleaned up the
vomit I found the toe
the toe so did we crazy right that story
is awesome indeed thank you for sharing
Jenny